on this day ten years ago Apple
customers got their hands on their very
first iPhones at the time Apple's
co-founder Steve Jobs promised the
devices would change the world well that
promise has been fulfilled the iPhone
and other smartphones that followed
shaped the way we wake up in the morning
get our news entertain our families and
even walk down the street
[Music]
every once in a while a revolutionary
product comes along that changes
everything I've just never seen anything
that comes close to this for one single
product ever all right show me this baby
so did anybody call you from their new
iPhone yet this is Amy I think you
butt-dialed me I remember when people
lined up to get that phone let's see the
new phone all right yeah you would have
been the plastic over me me Apple said
today that demand for its new iPhones
has now exceeded the supply I appreciate
that
somebody give me a phone
I don't know how to work this it's just
extraordinary
oh yeah good question
Robert sapien is editor-in-chief of Fast
Company magazine and he joins us at the
table good morning morning significant
milestone for Apple yes it is it is ten
years it's it's you know we forget that
when the iPhone first came out it wasn't
uniformly loved right people were
worried about that it was on a subpar
platform with AT&T if had didn't have
the type pad that everyone loved on
their crack Perry's it was loved by some
hated or different derided by others the
the idea of a touchscreen was not
universally loved and yet of course now
it is the the prevailing phenomenon has
changed so much in our world like like
well if you think back to 10 years ago
the predominant companies the largest
most valuable companies were energy
companies and maybe banks now they're
all technology companies right it's
Apple it's Google we talk about Facebook
we talk about Amazon all of them there
their power comes from what we're doing
on our mobile devices and then the
change in mobile if you think about uber
right Airbnb Spotify all of these things
the whole idea of an app store and what
we do on our phones with apps all of
this comes out of the inspiration that
the iPhone created so Bob there's no
question it transformed all of our
worlds but now they have real
competition for Android there are other
people in this game and the question is
can they stay on top they have to bring
out a new iPhone come fall well they
will continue to come in you know what's
going to be in that new iPhone no I
don't know nobody nobody really papers
say there's gonna be three iPhones and
one of them is gonna include kind of
this glass back it's going to be an inch
larger the question is yes and
eventually it will become accustomed
iPhone of your own size right they're
gonna offer you everything under the Sun
I think in the long run if you're gonna
look out to the next ten years right
what's gonna change things on the next
front you have to look at things like
the development of 5g the broader
bandwidth that you're gonna be able to
get on phones more things that are gonna
be able to be delivered to us in more
time and the changes that are going to
come across being able to use your
phones in healthcare and in education
you know think about now you flying a
plane you use your phone right you use
your phone to check into an airport
Network to a television you story the
other day about Facebook hitting 2
billion users you say Facebook wouldn't
be what it is Twitter wouldn't be what
it is but this is what fascinates me you
can have your Blackberry or Android your
Samsung they can all do the same thing
yes but you still say that the King
belongs all the credit belongs to iPhone
Y iPhone was the inspiration for the
cultural change that we have gone
through where we now have the Internet
in our pocket all the time right and
that is what that is what the iPhone
broke through for us again Samsung does
deliver that right your other your other
smartphones do deliver that but nothing
inspires it the way the iPhone there is
one big change Steven jobs I mean he
insisted on things like the touchscreen
whenever he said it was the wrong idea
do they still have that ruthless
creativity that Steve Jobs brought to
the table Apple is so much larger and
more dominant today than it was when
Steve Jobs passed away and we don't give
Tim Cook enough credit about the way
that company has scaled but there is a
momentum behind Apple that no one would
want to give up what that momentum is
they are at the top of it it's their
game to lose and they haven't cracked at
this point so big step up with a new
iPhone right yeah it's gonna be exciting
ok great Bob Safian thank you so much
for being here